lady de huit enfants ont été conçus mais
dans le feu des raids israéliens
ils sont accompagnés jusqu'à leur
dernière demeure par une foule à la fois
endeuillée et en colère comme cela
arrive souvent dans ces circonstances
tragiques des générations de
palestiniens se sont demandés pourquoi
israël cible des enfants une fois au
cimetière ces questions restent sans
réponse
c'est le plus grand malheur 2014
2008-2012 une chose pareille ne s'est
jamais produite auparavant à gaza on
reste à la maison dans la tente d'une
nouvelle frappe et dans la crainte que
nos enfants puissent nourrir le monde
entier de se mobiliser
les raids aériens israéliens confirme
que la politique de jérusalem ne change
pas la terre et brûlé constatent les
palestiniens debout devant les décombres
de leur maison
une frappe a été lancée contre la
famille d' adam khatib sur un bâtiment
de trois étages qui s'est effondré sur
les têtes des résidents ont dormi huit
enfants et deux femmes ont été tuées et
tout le quartier a subi des destructions
massives
voilà ce que je veux dire aux israéliens
et au monde entier regarde et qui est
opprimé ici et qui est oppresseurs qui
est un terroriste et qui ne l'est pas
qui tue des enfants et qui ne les tue
pas aujourd'hui huit enfants sont morts
en un instant cela montre au monde qui
est le vrai terroriste les palestiniens
de gaza rejettent la version israélienne
selon laquelle les mouvements armés
palestiniens utilisent des civils comme
boucliers humains
selon eux il n'est pas compliqué de
faire la différence entre des lance
roquettes et des enfants nous sommes
choqués par ce qui s'est passé cette
nuit
nous savons que les israéliens ont toute
la technologie possible à disposition et
tout ce qu'ils font ils le font avec
précision la technologie l'aéronautique
c'est incroyable qu'ils aient attaqué et
tiré des missiles sur cette maison
dix enfants ou neuf enfants et leur mère
comment peuvent-ils faire ça quand ils
savent que cette maison est pleine
d'enfants ont dépit de tous les
palestiniens ont hérité de leurs
ancêtres la capacité à surmonter toutes
ces épreuves
et ont bien appris que la mémoire est
plus forte que les mensonges et les
falsifications